28 ans serait entré par la porte de côté
de cette école chrétienne privée avant
d'ouvrir le feu tue en trois enfants
âgés de 8 et 9 ans et trois adultes qui
étaient dans la soixantaine à 10h13 le
91 reçoit un premier appel 14 minutes
plus tard Audrey tabattu par des
policiers et n'aura pas eu le temps
d'entrer dans les classes
a été rapide dit-il au deuxième étage
les policiers l'ont vu tirer des coups
de feu après des échanges de tir ils
l'ont abattuals
[Musique]
c'est la 129e tuerie depuis le mois de
janvier aux États-Unis ce qui est
l'équivalent de près de deux tuiles par
jour
je suis sans mot dit la première dame
nos enfants méritent mieux
selon des témoins Audrey heal est armé
jusqu'aux dents et avait deux fusils
d'assaut et un pistolet sont la police
elle s'identifie comme une personne
transgenre
c'est une ancienne élève de l'école dit
le chef de police qui affirme que
l'attaque était planifié méticuleusement
nous avons un manifeste dit-il une carte
qui décrit comment l'attaque allait se
dérouler
c'est malade dit le président ça brise
le cœur et déchire nos communautés il
faut bannir les fusils d'assaut
ajoutent-ils
sur son compte Twitter la représentante
républicaine morte green écrit qu'il
faut au contraire armer les écoles pour
mieux les protéger avec une majorité
républicaine dans la chambre des
représentants les fusils d'assaut ne
risquent pas d'être bénis de sitôt ici
Radio-Canada Washington